welcome to the
we're a Leadership Forum my name is
Kenneth Pruett I'm the vice president
for global centers and my pleasure is to
welcome president Ollie from the Islamic
Development Bank today and say that on
behalf of the University we are very
honored by your presence and we look
forward to a lively discussion with our
students and faculty and to welcome to
the podium professor Jeff Sachs who will
give a more proper introduction to our
guest professor Jeff Sachs as you know
is the director of the Earth Institute
and I think the president knows that the
earth Institute is is one of the most
innovative structures centers institutes
in higher education around the world it
has a very deep scientific basis with
the scientists up in lamont-doherty but
it also does a large amount of
development work direct development work
around the world in almost every world
country I sometimes quip that I think
the Earth Institute operates in more
countries than the UN has yet
acknowledged
creating countries as it goes and Jeff
Sachs of course has brought enormous
energy and leadership to the Earth
Institute since he's been here and the
entire campus takes a great deal of
pride in in his accomplishments and the
accomplishments of his senior leadership
and indeed of all the scientists who are
working did the Earth Institute
projects around the world in courting
including of course the lynnium
development villages initiative and so
forth so please welcome Jeff Sachs to
the podium
ladies and gentlemen were extremely
privileged today the president of the
Islamic Development Bank dr. Ahmed
Mohamed Ali al-madani this is an
enormous privilege and honor for us mr.
president for you to be here as I'll
describe in just a moment the Earth
Institute and the Islamic Development
Bank have entered into a wonderful
partnership and common striving for work
in the member states of the Islamic
Development Bank to fight poverty and to
promote economic development so it's a
special privilege to have you and your
colleagues with us again today after a
wonderful visit
in June president Holley is a national
of Saudi Arabia with the absolutely
illustrious career and leadership
throughout the Islamic world but he also
has some very important parts of his
life in in New York and in in the United
States as well he was educated with the
BA degree in commerce and law from Cairo
University and then earned master's and
PhD in public administration from the
University of Michigan and from the
University State University of New York
at Albany and so we know you're a New
Yorker also at heart and it's great to
have you here
I after his university degrees President
Ali returned to work in it both academic
and development work in Yemen and then
as Acting rector of the King Abdulaziz
University in Jeddah then in 1975 the
organization of the Islamic Conference
now the Organization of Islamic
Cooperation decided to create
a Development Bank for the Islamic
countries and naturally they turned to
President Ali to become the first
president of the Bank and he has done
such a remarkable job in guiding this
institution to become one of the most
important Regional Development or it's
not regional it's it's worldwide but one
of the most important multilateral
Development Bank's I should say in the
world that he has served as the first
president from 1975 to 1993 and then
asked to continue to serve as president
from 1995 until today and the bank has
thrived and has a remarkable reach when
you think about it there are 56 member
countries of the Islamic Development
Bank and combined population of those
member countries is 1.5 billion people
so this is a bank which has a worldwide
reach that covers also more than 20% of
the world's population stretching from
the Americas to North Africa the Middle
East sub-saharan Africa and all parts of
Asia it's an incredibly exciting
institution with the span from some of
the world's poorest nations to some of
the world's richest nations but with a
commitment to share the development
experience across all of these countries
and with a great vision and a great
ethic behind this commitment to ensure
shared prosperity across the Islamic
world one of the exciting aspects of the
bank and one that brings presidental
lead to the talk today is the
outstanding financial record of the bank
and its outstanding credit rating I say
only with the mild amount of envy but
mostly with admiration that the bank is
a triple-a organization something we can
no longer say
the US Treasury but and and among fewer
and fewer countries in the world fewer
and fewer governments but the banks
triple-a rating was just recently
reconfirmed and this is a demonstration
of the very sound financial principles
that have governed the bank I'm thrilled
mr. president that we signed a
Memorandum of Understanding in June to
create a very dynamic broad and engaging
partnership on many aspects of the
bank's work we at the earth Institute
are committed absolutely to our core in
sustainable development around the world
we are working in so many of the member
countries of the Islamic Development
Bank that we see your good works and we
have the absolute logic and the felt
need to partner together and see in a
shared way the opportunities that this
partnership can bring about our
partnership just to mention very very
briefly will include a tremendous effort
on community-based development
especially throughout sub-saharan Africa
a part will include the partnership of
the bank with the Millennium villages
project a part will be the earth
Institute's support for sustainable
village initiative of the Islamic
Development Bank and part will be a
partnership of both the bank and the
Earth Institute behind a six government
initiative in the Horn of Africa called
the dry land initiative where these
governments in the face of drought have
come together to raise the living
conditions and the long-term prospects
of the pastoralist communities and this
is an area where we will be working
together our teams are out in the field
right now together and Chad and Sudan
and it's already a partnership that is
delivering the real results on the
ground
and joint work together so it's
extremely gratifying now President Ali
asked to speak today about a topic that
is obviously of pivotal importance and
that is about the international
financial crisis and the essentially the
crisis of debt in in the global economy
were everyday being rattled by more and
more banking and sovereign debt crises
one just has to look at any news report
hour by hour to ask which Bank has more
recently been downgraded in Europe which
sovereign debt is under attack whether
the European Union will be able to get
its act together to address the Greek
crisis or whether there will be a
spillover of that crisis to other
countries I think President Ali has an
important message to talk to us about
today about ways that Islamic finance
and different approaches to finance that
may prevent or address this kind of
systemic crisis so we're very eager to
hear your words and your guidance and
we're especially thrilled to be
welcoming you back to Columbia
University today mr. president
smilla Rahman al Rahim very delighted
really to be here at the Colombians
world leaders forum with this
distinguished audience let me first of
all thank my dear friend professor
Jeffrey Sachs for inviting me to
Columbia University I would also like to
thank dr. Kenneth trivet for his
introductory remarks I am pleased to
speak to you today about a subject that
has gained crucial importance in the
wake of the global financial crisis the
current crisis which as you know started
in two 0:08 was described by the
governor of the United Kingdom financial
services authority mr. Adrienne Turner
as arguably the greatest crisis in the
history of Finance capitalism it look it
took around 18 trillion dollars or more
than 30% of the world gross output by a
number of industrial countries to
stabilize the financial system and to
revive the international economy
nevertheless the adverse effects of the
crisis
still persist through continuing
economic slowdown and rising and
employment the crisis which according to
most analysts originated from subprime
lending in the United States housing
sector soon spread as a wild fire to the
whole world the financial crisis rapidly
turned into a global economic crisis
affecting the real sectors in all
economies of the world both rich and
poor with different degrees ordinary
people worldwide in descent by standards
who cannot be conceivably related to the
causes of the crisis were caught off
guard and their livelihood affected the
most vulnerable ones in the society
suffered the most particularly as the
commodity prices skyrocketed as a
multilateral development financial
institution we in the semuc Development
Bank group helplessly observed the
already scarce funding for poverty
related programs in developing countries
dry up as the resources were diverted
away from development needs the work of
many years on social advancement was
hampered and the suffering of the poor
and this advantage continues to increase
day after day this only shows how
interconnected and interdependent the
world we live in it also shows how
responsible we should be in managing and
governing the financial and economic
systems this crisis particularly
indicated how fragile our financial
system has become with unprecedented
growth of debt the world has experienced
more than a hundred financial crises
since 1945 this make it incumbent upon
all of us to look for a new architecture
that minimizes the frequency and
severity of such crises in the future
the architecture of the global financial
system and its governance structure are
currently as you know being reviewed by
the g20 leaders with this in mind I will
try today to reflect on some of the
ideas that could be considered while
embarking on this review I will also try
to shed some light on the potential
contribution of the emerging Islamic
financial industry to enhancing the
stability and resilience of the global
financial system which are sent
chill to development and growth since it
is not possible to think of a better
architecture without first determining
the primary cause of the crisis
let me first shed some light on the
primary cause of the financial crisis in
the past decades the generally
recognized most important cause of
almost all of this crisis has been
excessive and imprudent lending this
raises the question of what makes it
possible for banks or lenders in general
to resort to such an unhealthy practice
of indulging excessively in high-risk
lending which does not only destabilize
the financial system but also not in
their own real interest in the long term
there are many factors that explain this
however they shall focus today on one
which i think is important and relevant
to the subject of my topic this factor
relates to the inadequate market
discipline in the financial system
resulting from inadequate risk sharing
practices the false sense of immunity
from losses caused by the inadequate
risk sharing has introduced a fault line
in the financial system consequently
many banks do not usually exercise
proper do you do diligence in their
drive for profit maximization this leads
to unhealthy expansion in the overall
volume of credit excessive leverage and
an sustainable rise in asset prices and
speculative investment unwinding later
on gives rise to a steep decline in
asset prices and to financial Ferengi
ability and debt crisis particularly if
there is also over indulgence in short
sales don't cloud Trishelle president of
the European Central Bank has rightly
pointed that a bubble is more likely to
develop when investors can leverage
their positions by investing borrowed
funds furthermore when lenders
imprudent and then beyond the capacity
of the borrower's to repay the resort to
complex instruments to protect
themselves
this practice ends up expanding the debt
market even further these complex
instruments create a trade market
whereby traders buy and sell debt to
make quick profits with no real asset
being created no real economic value
being added
the delinking of profit-making
from the real economy is a major cause
of excessive lending and is at the heart
of my subject today to start with it is
important to underline the imperative of
risk sharing that Islamic finance
encourages through its emphasis on
equity sells best and lease based
financing instrument who I'll get it
allowed in Islamic finance which is not
allowed to grow on its own it can grow
only in step with the growth of the real
sector just by integrating debt creation
with wealth creation finance is properly
positioned as means of promoting
productive activities and cannot be used
for speculation
or be an end in itself this prevents the
creation of an inverted debt pyramid and
thereby largely mitigates financial
instability experience shows there are
2n creditors take an active role in the
underlying economic transaction they
become more prudent in extending credit
this introduces greater discipline into
the financial system by motivating
financial institutions to assess the
risks more carefully and effect
monitoring the use of the funds by the
burrowers the dual assessment of risks
by both the lender al de boer war
injects greater discipline into the
system and reduces excessive lending
therefore the most preferred forms of
Islamic finance partnership and profit
and loss sharing renewed efforts in the
wake of the current global financial
crisis in search of a more resilient and
robust financial system based on
stronger links between credit and the
real economy brought some attention to
Islamic finance the principles of
Islamic finance can minimize the
severity and frequency of financial
crises by introducing greater discipline
into the financial system and requiring
the financial to bear or share in the
risk Islamic finance also requires the
creditors to bear the risk of default by
prohibiting the sale of debt thereby
creating a proper enabling environment
for insuring risk mitigation through
sound due diligence by those who extend
credits before closing let me briefly
highlight some aspects of the Islamic
financial system that I believe can
contribute to the ongoing efforts of
reforming the global financial system
these aspects include first to increase
the share of equity and reduce the share
of debt in the total financing of
economic activities second who in the
need of debt is justified it should be
extended based on sound due diligence
that includes logical risk reward
consideration third credit should be
confined primarily to transactions that
are linked to the real sector to ensure
that credit expansion moves more or less
in tandem with the growth of the real
economy fourth all financial
institutions not just banks need to be
properly regulated and supervised so
that they remain healthy and do not
become the source of systemic risk fifth
respite should be given to debtors who
are in real distress beyond their
control the giving of respite in such
circumstances along with the necessary
restructuring with Islamic fairness
requires would also help reduce the
rapid downward slide in asset prices
caused by the fourth auction of
borrowers assets let me emphasize
that the principles of Islamic finance
are not are not specific to the Islamic
faith we are part of not only most
divine religions but also circular
paradigms
therefore the underlying principles of
Islamic finance have been described as
ethical and universal The Economist
magazine has rightly observed that the
world needs new ways of thinking about
finance and the risks the risks it
involves I humbly believe that Islamic
finance offers basic principles for this
purpose at a time when world leaders are
calling for deep financial reforms it is
important to have our financial systems
rebuilt and widely accepted ethical and
moral basis to serve the common good of
humanity
once again dear ladies and gentlemen I
wish to thank my dear brother Jeffrey
Sachs also to thank Columbia University
for inviting me to speak at this
Columbia's world leaders forum and I
would also like to thank all of you
audience for your interest and attention
thank you very much for Salam alaikum
mr. president thank you for those
wonderful remarks we're going to have
question and answer and I would
encourage students in particular but
anybody to line up we have two
microphones I would ask you to identify
yourself and your position in the Pro
and a program here or what brings you to
the community I wanted to know mr.
president I think there's a wonderful
relationship between the precepts that
you outlined and some ideas in that have
come in us academic circles led by a
professor at Boston University named
Laurence Kotlikoff on limited purpose
banking and the idea of limited purpose
banking is to stop the fractional
reserve leveraging of the banks but
banks would become more like mutual
funds in fact when you buy a bank you're
actually buying some equity ownership in
the underlying assets that this
institution is lending to and so there's
always a backing of the deposits with
the underlying assets and it's the same
principle and I will make the connection
he's a dear friend and has been
promoting this kind of financial reform
so I will make the connection and I
think it's it will be quite interesting
to show that the principles that you've
enunciated of Islamic finance are
finding the real resonance in the
financial theories in post prices so I I
find that very very very exciting let me
turn first here to first question if you
would identify yourself please yes Molly
Colley my name is Islamic Cultural
Center dr. Ali between the Bronx and
Manhattan there is only one Islamic
Middle School which is our school
Islamic Leadership School
and in 2002 we have applied funding from
your bank which was approved in 2005 and
we received dr. Mohammed Salim from the
special assistance unit two times at our
school and ever since we have not
received across London or anything from
the bank so you are wondering if the
project that was approved which we have
the evidence is still approve or it's
been canceled and I brought some of our
students here from the school thank you
very much thank you so I hope that
you'll make the connections to answer
yeah first of all I want to comment
brothers on the assets what you
mentioned about this band is similar to
the so cook IDP now is mobilizing
resources from the market through those
to cook so cook also also is directly
connected with actual asset the bank has
so it is related to real properties
projects most of them are leasing or an
installment sale we use it for hours to
cook so does the the borrowing of IDP
from the market it is actually related
directly to the actual projects which we
are financing so to the real economy for
selling this question brother I am very
sorry I not know about this school but I
promise you now you give me a copies of
correspondence I promise you I will
follow it insha'Allah and we hear an
answer within one week insha'Allah
if people could maybe raise the mic out
okay I really speak into the mic hi my
name is Thomas Paul I'm from the law
school mr. president
regarding the principles that you just
enunciated can you describe a little
more on how they can be applied
should they be some certain principles
that the global governance organizations
should adopt in their charters or in
their day-to-day decision-making
or should say company executives or bank
executives before assumed in such
management positions read over these
principles and maybe in a written
statement agree to abide by certain
principles were making their decisions
thank you actually I'm not advocating to
have Islamic banking as a terrorist do
what is practice now I'm just saying
that in the restructuring of the world
financial system we take in
consideration these principles in other
words there should be controlled on the
excessive lending and also the banks
should also take risk in lending this
means they should follow also the
projects with the Atlantic along with
the borrowers so these points we wanted
to be a part of the new financial system
we are not advocating this to be another
alternative I want to be clear on that
so my advice is that they just benefit
from this principle in our new system a
new new financial system a new banking
system I hope I am clear on that
yes assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam
welcome to LA he brokered my name is
Manny and I'm a first year undergraduate
my question is how long do you think
it'll take before we see major lenders
in the West start to adopt more of these
principles and adopt more risk in their
lending but do the question now
how long will it take before we see
these practices adopted in the Western
banking institutions yes yes of course
consider this question we are advocating
we are suggesting I mentioned in the
restructuring of the new financial
system the policy makers to take in
consideration these principles in order
to minimize the crises of the future
over their repetition as well as their
severity this what you are suggesting
maybe you could I add just a word about
some of the dynamics that we've seen
this past weekend one of the motivations
for the current system is the benefits
to the managers the CEOs because they
take high risks when they win they take
home billions of dollars in pay and when
they lose their shareholders go go
bankrupt but they walk away fine even
they get invited still to the white
house the next week so it's a general
agreement not I would say these
principles but that there should be a
movement towards less risk and more
capital in the banks and less leveraging
but presidenta Lee is putting further
that that core practices should change
but even on the modest changes the
bankers are pushing back very hard and
the somebody who's considered the lead
Wall Street banker right now Jamie Dimon
from JPMorgan had a shouting match over
the weekend with the governor of the
Bank of Canada because he objected to
more stringent capital requirements put
on the bank mr. Dimon wants big salaries
big bonuses big incomes and he wants
government to bear the risk if the banks
failed that there will be a bailout the
rest of society is pushing that who will
win is a big question because mr. Dimon
pays a lot more campaign contributions
he and his colleagues than his
depositors do /
so this is a matter of power and
influence as well as proper principle
the banking regulation mr. president my
name is Rehema and I'm a second year
masters students at the School of
International and public affairs and
throughout the crisis there was a lot of
mention in the press both Western and
elsewhere that the Islamic financial
system was really exceptional in being
able to withstand the issues that were
happening but the case of the Islamic
bank of Britain showed a bank that
showed a lot of promise but in a few
years was really on the brink of
bankruptcy and neither the cash
injection injection from its investors
in Qatar to be able to stand on its feet
and I'm just wondering what you think
the factors were that led to this really
quick change in just a few years and
whether these factors were internal to
the bank or true for the entire Islamic
banking industry thank you I'm sorry are
you saying that Bank banks in Inc in
England go into bankruptcy no I'm saying
the Islamic bank of Britain which was
instituted in 2004 only a few years
later lost like 96 percent of its share
value and needed millions of dollars of
cash from its Qatari investors to be
able to survive banks Britain there's
this single institution system of
management could be any other reasons
but as you know Islamic banks as a whole
as a whole as an industry it is the most
growing industry in the world this to
match their growth annual growth 15% all
over the world whether it is in OSE
member countries or outside OSE member
countries so the industry as a whole I
think it is it is growing very rapidly
and they are flourishing they proved
also to be more resilient in the
financial crisis as you know of course
they were not affected by the financial
crisis they were affected by the
economic crisis who in the financial
crisis because became economic crisis
and everybody affected also some
segments have been affected but as a
whole if you look into all the documents
of the IMF and others you find that the
Islamic banks were more resilient for
the financial crisis so if that happened
in English is just a single Bank but not
the industry as a whole
Thank You mr. president
I'm heard a little I'm a first-year
undergraduate here at the college and
I'd like to preface my question with the
fact that my economic knowledge is
limited to an introductory course I took
in high school so with that in mind it's
my understanding that the that your bank
um operates or that your group operates
under Sharia which is which entails no
interests correct like the the belief
and no system of interests or anything
like that if I'm correct correct me if
I'm wrong please but so with that with
that system in place how does that do
you think that this should be something
that should be looked at when we're
looking at Corrections for international
finance system and also how does that
system of no-interest affect your
dealings with other banking groups and
with other financial systems thank you
the Islamic Development Bank is now
almost 37 years old and all its
operation is done on the principles of
Nan interest at the back developed a
number of modes of financing all of them
do not include interest but I want to
again be clear here I am NOT at
in Islamic banking to be adopted as a
whole where I am just proposing that
elements of Islamic banking to be
considered in restructuring the new
financial order internationally but
ceramic banks has been proved and has
been practiced in many countries as you
know whether they are in Muslim
countries in non-muslim countries also
in Muslim countries has been practiced
by Muslims and non-muslims like in
Malaysia there is a Chinese bank who is
operating in accordance with an interest
basis and so forth so the system itself
did prove itself in the past 35 years
but at the same time I want to repeat am
not advocating that to be the
international system I am just
suggesting that elements of this system
to be injected in the new financial
international order to benefit from
these principles in order to have less
dependence on debts and mainly on risk
sharing in order to put a limit to
excessive lending that's my message
thank you dr. Ali and dr. Sachs I did
want to help get a sense of the status
of you undergo your negotiations and
recommendations to other regional bodies
particularly the African Development
Bank and some of the states which you
know are going through elections now
particularly Mali
every cost to enter the spectrums I'm a
firm believer in worst-case scenarios if
as dr. stack says Europe and American
base and internationally based
institutions do not in fact listen to
your recommendations even on a small
scale would you give us a sense of what
your recommendations are to certain
regional bodies to quarantine themselves
from a double-dip or even a full-blown
depression and how they can actually put
up some of the barriers by which they
could defend their economic system and
the viability of their nation states and
their populations are they against a
contagion that has all the possibilities
of breaking out thank you I'm certain it
was you know it's a acoustics are tough
the question is given that the European
and US banks might not listen to this
advice and the regulator's and there
could be another hit how would you
recommend that institutions protect
themselves against what could be another
wave of downturn or crisis so mainly the
question of insulation from the global
shocks yes my advice to those
institutions to benefit from the
principles and the practice of Islamic
banking in other words to do less
excessive lending to be more prudent in
dealing with your customers you should
be sure that your the price the success
of the project is acceptable don't just
give the loan and go and sleep give the
loan and follow it I think if this
principle really has been accepted
we will not today
have the problem of the debts especially
in developing countries
because most of the debt in the world
countries came before because there is
no follow-up from the banks and the
institution holding this money if they
gave them their experience in
administration if they followed with
them the implementation of the projects
I'm sure will have been a better world
today so my advice is to try to benefit
from these principles which I mentioned
and to know your customers very well and
to follow up about your loans don't just
give it and go and give it to the to the
people whom you are lending your money
to this is my advice I hope it answered
your question thank you Salam doctor
thank you very much my name is Josh
Keller I'm a first year masters of
development practice student here at
Columbia School of International and
public affairs and my question is
regarding the transition to some of your
policies which I really a huge fan of
but sadly especially with the US economy
we live in a world where it's driven by
personal incentives and it's been driven
by those personal incentives of those
down on Wall Street so how do we
transition to this system that really
lacks most of those personal incentives
which I truly believe needs to be done
but how do we work in this world driven
by incentives to move out of that maybe
we could address something we could do
here in the States but maybe more on a
global scale as well thank you you can
absolutely depend okay no no not at all
how to manage a transition to these
principles of finance from where we are
today what would be the key steps step
by step for the transition the
transition
I suggest of course now the whole crisis
are dealt with forums you have the g20
forum for example they are working on
the new financial order
I suggest that the bankers
together they can put rules and
regulations and also principles new
principles of how to deal with the
customers how to deal with the debts and
they can suggest to g20 for example and
this to be globally adopted and also as
you know you have the IMF they can play
a major role in that also so I think we
can as bankers or developmental bankers
we can together build a system that you
can suggest it to the g20 to the
International Monetary Fund in order
these ideas could be accepted and
international understandings
could be issued for the regulator's of
the central banks worldwide I would also
suggest you might look at professor
Kotlikoff recent writing because he also
tries to take on a specific transition
away from fractional reserve leverage
banking to what he calls limited purpose
banking which has analogies to the
Islamic finance and so you might look at
that as a technical pathway that he's
suggesting is some ideas about how a
transition could be made place will take
two more two more questions Thank You
President Ali for coming to speak to us
today my name is mano Javed I'm a
student I'm a student at the Masters of
the violent practice at the
International School of International
Affairs my question is given that Libya
is the second largest shareholder of the
bank owning
the son of the shares with a change in
the Libyan regime is that does that pose
a has that posed a threat on the funding
for the bank
given that who's the second largest
Libya Libya Libya oh okay
implications of Libya being a large
shareholder of the Bank does that pose
implications for the bank no not at all
really of course until now ID be is not
operating in Libya now but IDP will be
very ready Libya is founding one of the
major founding members of the Cermak
Development Bank and ITB will be very
happy to fully cooperate with them to
provide technical assistance as well as
to provide other modes of financing in
order to help them at this stage they
are in need of course mainly to find
jobs for the for the young people and
IDP could participate through micro
financing program which we are
considering now for Tunis and Egypt and
we can consider it also for Libya so I
don't think there is any negative effect
because there is no also over use or any
big problems in Libya so we don't expect
any problem but we will be ready to
provide assistance to the Libyan
government to the new Libyan government
last question I a Marilyn suit I am
first-year student at school of
international affairs and I want to ask
like do you find the policies which are
implemented in Greece to find them right
and we have another suggestions for to
cure the problems in Greece
I missed it also sir I wondered if you
see the Michael country yeah I wonder if
mr. president find the policies
implemented in Greece
right to cure the economic problems in
Greece in Greece Greece yes okay the
question is about the Greek crisis yeah
if you would care we are not involved
because Greece is not a member of IDB
and we don't have any relationship
economic or financial relationship but
of course the Greek problem may affect
the Europe as a whole of course we are
very much engaged in with Europe where
you have big deals with European banking
system we have a lot of cooperation with
them we have deposits we have many deals
that most likely may affect us because
if any problems with the major European
banks this will affect definitely IDB so
we have to reassess our relationship but
we don't have direct relationship with
with Greece mr. Presiden I wonder if I
could ask you one one last question
which is about compensation of bankers
because what the compensation of bankers
one of the motivations of the risky
behavior of the bankers on Wall Street
was the huge pay that they were
receiving huge bonuses each Christmas
time I watched as 30 billion dollars
went out the door to a small group of
people and I thought it was amazing and
it was amazing in that their banks
collapsed but they all became very very
rich does Islamic finance also have
guidance about executive compensation
and and also the ethics of CEO
compensation something that we could
learn from yes of course as you know the
Islamic banking system have a number of
levels of regulation and supervision and
control first of all they are under the
regulatory system of the country where
they are for example
an Islamic bank say in in United Arab
Emirates first of all it is under
deregulated by the central bank net arab
emirates so there is control for that
second there also they have special
sharia a committee a committee it is
outside that which is like external
auditors but for the Syria point of view
they also have supervision on the
activities of the bank and they have to
issued annual certificates besides of
course external auditors so all and also
we have a number of institutions like
you fee which is issue standards
accounting standard and other standards
we have also the IFSP the Islamic
financial addressed Board which is
located in Kuala Lumpur
they also issued standards so with all
this supervision understand that
hopefully this could be controlled in
the Islamic banking system until now I
didn't hear of any serious problem like
that for the Islamic box but it could
happen but in any case there is a number
of supervisory and regulatory
authorities which I don't say that
it will remove such a problem but it
will really be very much minimized Thank
You mr. president I want to thank you
for an extremely exciting and very clear
presentation and very thought-provoking
for all of us living a mile from Wall
Street which doesn't quite behave on
these principles right now but you've
given us a lot of thought about prudence
morals and ethics in finance also and
I'm sure that we'll be discussing these
thoughts for a long time to come here as
I mentioned it
an incredible honor for us to partner
with the Islamic Development Bank at
Columbia and I want to say to the
students here that as we embark on this
partnership in the three major programs
that I mentioned the Millennium villages
program the sustainable villages program
and the drylands initiative we're always
eager for student participation as
research assistants interns
and many other ways so you can always
express your interest to me sacks at
Columbia edu very easy to find your
email will be forwarded I tell you two
people working on these various projects
but it will not be lost and it won't be
lost in the shuffle
it will people that would like to be
engaged in these projects we want you to
be engaged because this is about the
university as a community you can see
how exciting it is for us to have this
partnership and I do hope you will be
engaged let me therefore with that note
finally conclude by giving our warmest
thanks to president Ali and to all his
colleagues for this wonderful talk and
for being with us today at Columbia
University with your permission thank
you I want also to mention that Islamic
Development Group has a Research
Institute we call it early Islamic
research and Training Institute will be
very happy to fully cooperate with any
professor or students who are interested
in Islamic banking or Islamic economics
through this era t we could establish
contacts with the professors and the
students who are interested and we can
exchange information and we give them
any publications of the air T as well
the REA number of research papers has
been issued by RT it could be available
through the site of the group or through
L T thank you very much thank thank you